مجموعه الاتصال الدفاعيه الاوكرانيه
المؤلفه من 50 دوله تجتمع في قاعده
تيرانشتاين الجويه الامريكيه في المانيا
الاتفاق على حزمه جديده وكبيره من
المساعدات العسكريه لكيف مساله ارسال
دبابات ليوبارد الالمانيه وموافقه برلين
على صادرات من دوله ثالثه الى اوكرانيا
ستكون واحده من الموضوعات الرئيسيه مع
املي دبلوماسيين اوروبيين بان تسمح
المانيا للحلفاء بارسال التلك الدبابات في
دعم اوكرانيا ضد رؤوس
من قسمه حول هذه القضيه
فاشركاؤها في الائتلاف حزب الخضر
والديمقراطيون الاحرار يفضلون ارسال
الدبابات الى اوكرانيا بينما كثيرون في
الحزب الاشتراكي الديمقراطي للميول
اليساريه بما فيهم المستشار نفسه كانوا
مترددين منذ فتره طويله خاصه وان الولايات
المتحده ترفض رساله دبابات ابرامز الخاصه
بها